hey david are anti-trump republicans
sort of a third party now will they
become a formal third party going
forward
my instinct is no and i know that a lot
of you have been following very closely
groups like the lincoln project which
are made up mostly
of disaffected republicans who believe
that the republican party under donald
trump is not really the republican party
uh of of pre-donald trump which is true
in many senses
um and and uh could this split off could
this permanently fracture the republican
party i think the answer is no and
it's no for a couple of different
reasons number one
if the republican party for more
formally fractures
and you've got sort of like the trumpian
republicans and then more traditional
pre-trump republicans it helps democrats
dramatically because it splits the
right-wing vote
republicans know this and so it would be
dealing a huge amount of self-inflicted
damage if the democratic party doesn't
split
a split in the republican party destroys
the possibilities of many republicans
from getting re-elected so on a
practical level i don't think they're
going to do it
but there's another reason which is that
until i see evidence otherwise
these groups like the lincoln project
and other anti-trump republicans mitt
romney etc
this is temporary if biden wins things
go back to the way they were
in terms of their opposition to
democratic uh policy democratic ideas
even when the democratic ideas are only
marginally more
left than the mainstream republican
ideas as they are in some cases the
lincoln project
is it's a pre-trump republican party
and that means that it is um
immediately going to go back to saying
what joe biden wants to do is bad
joe biden building a climate proposal on
the green new deal is bad joe biden
wanting to
uncap social security earnings and
eliminate the
stepped-up basis clause and all of the
they're against all of that stuff and so
but my my belief is that this ends
as soon as soon as uh
donald trump is out of office now
there's one sort of caveat to this
um a lot of these anti-trump republicans
have said they aren't going to go back
to the republican party
that the the idea being they've burnt
their bridges that by opposing donald
trump
they've also ruined relationships with
some of the more
uh traditional mainstream republicans
who are falling in line with trump and
that that's an irreparable relationship
number one history tells us otherwise
politics makes strange bedfellows
grudges that seem um
un unforgivable so to speak end up being
forgiven either explicitly or implicitly
and those same alliances end up being
formed so i just don't believe
that the the bridges have been burned
permanently the bridges can be rebuilt
but number two you can be out of the
republican party in some kind of strict
technical sense and still oppose
democrats and still end up voting for
future
republican candidates so i it's partly
that i don't believe them but partly
it's it could be a technicality now
in terms of my view i would love
multiple parties and i would love a
different voting system i've said before
the best path to empowering
parties other than republicans and
democrats in the united states
involves serious campaign finance reform
number one
and number two a different voting system
than first past the post because for as
long as we continue to have per first
pass the post
the spoiler effect of supporting a third
party candidate is too great
if i love the green party
and then would vote democratic and
really don't want a republican
i risk putting the republican in office
by voting for the green party
if on the right i'm actually you know
i don't know some far-right neo-nazi and
i want david duke
but if it's not david duke i'd prefer
trump and i really don't want joe biden
if i vote for david duke if he were
running
i actually risk putting joe biden in
office so
we've talked about that before i'm not
going to delve into that in more detail
now but i
i would prefer multiple parties i would
rather do away with the two-party
duopoly i've
i'm very interested in proportional
representation systems the likes of
which we have
uh we see in other countries although i
understand the risks of that and i'm not
ignoring them but until we do campaign
finance reform
and have something other than a
first-past-the-post system unless we go
in the direction of proportional
and and really think through what that
would look like uh
we're going to see the two-party duopoly
maintain
and uh that is an unfortunate reality
that we have to contend with we have
a tremendous bonus show for you today
get
instant access to it instant by becoming
a member at joinedpakman.com
or becoming a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow